in this video we're going to take a
journey in life and we're going to start
with the smallest scale of life that is
indisputably life and that is the cell
now the reason why i qualified that a
little bit is some people debate whether
viruses are living or not because they
have certain aspects viruses can
reproduce they do have genetic
information but they need other living
forms to reproduce in particular they
need other cells but even though we
imagine cells to be these very very
small
microscopic things they are in and of
themselves almost an entire world and we
go into depth into that into other
videos in khan academy but the fact that
every cell in your body except for a few
like red blood cells have all of your
genetic information in it all of those
three billion base pairs of dna that
make you a human being a human being in
and of itself is mind-boggling
but then the fact that the cell
specializes so that not all cells are
the same even though they have that same
genetic information they somehow know
what type of cell to be that's even more
interesting
so we could start at the most basic
building block in your body or really
any organism's body and that's
specialized cells
so what you're seeing here is a big
cluster of neurons which are dyed here
in the red and i believe these blues
show their actual nuclei where they have
their genetic information
and then dyed in green you have what are
called neuroglial cells which are other
types of cells that are inside the human
brain mainly to support neurons most of
what we believe is thought occurs
through triggering neurons which then
trigger other neurons and form cascades
of these electrochemical signals which
we're just starting to understand but
this is just one little small fraction
of a human brain a human brain for
example will have on the order of 80 to
90 billion neurons and for every one of
those neurons depending on what part of
the brain you're talking about you're
talking about five to ten neuroglial
cells so you're talking about many
hundreds of billions of cells just in
one human brain
but then if we were to zoom out a little
bit and you take a bunch of these
specialized cells working together or at
least near each other you have tissue
and so as i said before this is a zoomed
in view of neural tissue in particular
of brain tissue
and then if you zoom out a little bit
more the tissue makes up
organs
and if we're thinking about neural
tissue like this we can imagine that it
makes up the brain which is an organ
and then organs build up to systems
and right over here you have a picture
of the nervous system of which the brain
is apart you also have the spinal cord
and then you also have all of the nerves
that go throughout the body so we have a
system
and then you put all of the systems
together and you get the actual
organism
which of course you can somewhat
visualize right over here where you can
see all of these different organs and
organ systems put together to create who
we are and just to connect the organism
with the cells that basic building block
of life if you are a average size human
being you likely have 30 to 40 trillion
cells in your body and if that isn't
mind-blowing enough and it is just an
estimate it's estimated that there's as
many as a hundred trillion bacteria in
your body
and so even though you think you are
just quote an individual you are a
universe of living things in these
complex systems it's an interesting
question of why and right over here we
know that organisms interact with each
other we know that they interact with
their environment just as each of our
nerve cells might not appreciate that
they are one of 86 billion in the
sentient mind maybe we ourselves as
organisms don't appreciate that we too
are building blocks of maybe something
even larger